what if I told you the world is not as
it seems then what you think you know is
wrong that matrix references are still
cool well for conservatives on the
Internet the matrix is shockingly still
cool you take the blue pill and the
story area you take the red pill and we
follow the White Rabbit into the store
swallow
what is this storm the storm is a new
master conspiracy that's taking the
internet by let's just say it's big
remember pizza gate the two crazy not to
be true conspiracy that started on the
internet but ended with a man shooting
up a real pizza parlor with an ar-15 the
storm is similar but some experts
predict it's poised to have an even more
explosive real-world impact it's already
spreading faster than Pizza Gate and
it's big so big that the main hashtag
associated with it has been tweeted more
than five million times since late
October even sean hannity retweeted a
post mentioning cue a nom the shadowy
figure at the center of the storm and of
course this luminaries on board a lot of
what q anon has said I already had
gotten separately from my White House
sources my Pentagon sources and yes this
is happening the storm is really in
Newsweek called it the biggest
news story of 2018 but what exactly is
the storm its thesis is pretty simple
you see Robert Muller is an
investigating Trump at all in fact
Muller's working for Trump and his real
target is a corrupt cabal of deep state
globalists who he will round up and ship
to Guantanamo that series of arrests is
referred to as the storm and it's come
[Music]
but let's back up the storm started one
sunny day last October when Trump said
this storm you heard it
statement like that had to be
significant he's not the kind of guy who
likes being off the cuff I like being
loved because no this had to mean
something something a mysterious figure
known only as Q or Q Anand who began
posting about the storm on anonymous
internet message boards like 4chan and
Ageing the only place to get unfiltered
truth and uncensored technical warned
few claims to be a high-level government
agent with top-secret security clearance
which makes sense because he has so much
time to post on the Internet
three weeks after Trump's cryptic storm
reference Q made his first post
predicting that Hillary Clinton would be
arrested on October 30th 2017 which
definitely happened because followers
noticed her orthopedic boot must be
covering up an ankle monitoring bracelet
and is the only reasonable
interpretation of this picture since
that first post in late October Hugh's
been dropping cryptic clues called
crumbs almost daily his legion of
followers then collect these crumbs they
call themselves bakers which makes sense
because that's what bakers do they bake
cakes from the crumbs of other staler
cakes most crumbs are questions that
invite readers to draw their own
conclusions take for example this real
post from last month that I will now
read verbatim think image drop think
Opie think United when does a bird sing
everything has meaning
it could be a capital I or a lowercase L
qu so elegant so clear you see Q is like
Socrates or someone who doesn't have
enough information to make statements
luckily bakers are here to connect the
dots some theorize that the image drop
is Obama's portrait Opie and United
Airlines now flies nonstop to Cuba it's
a commercial airline which evades deep
state leakers birds sing when they're
caged so Q is telling us that Obama is
flying United to Gitmo where he'll
confess it's pretty obvious if you ask
me
sure critics call the storm a coping
mechanism for people who can't accept a
world where Trump isn't winning but I
can't accept that
instead I prefer the simple soothing
idea at the heart of the song that
everything that looks bad for Trump is
absolutely good for true and while
that's the center of the storm there are
even grander ideas living at the fringe
that's right we haven't even gotten to
the fringe yet you see the storm is a
sort of master conspiracy that connects
every conspiracy you already knows the
dossier thing the vegas shooting and
inside jobs the deep state connected to
Big Pharma and the Illuminati and say it
with me the Egyptian Sun God raw just a
moment author and journalist Kurt
Anderson what are you doing here you're
not an expert on this well I kind of am
an expert on this I just published a
book called Fantasyland about how these
kinds of nutty conspiracy theories and
all kinds of magical thinking really are
pretty fundamental to the American
character so you're saying there's
nothing more American than a conspiracy
we're saying the same no we're not
people can look at something like this
and say hey that's goofy that's silly
that's funny but there are a lot of
people in the millions who take this
kind of thing very seriously that's
where it can get dangerous and now it's
reached members of Congress and the
president who is really a kind of
conspiracy theorist in chief right
birtherism not conspiracy millions of
people illegally voting a conspiracy the
storm is just a short hop skip away from
those kinds of thinking so conspiracies
are heading mainstream yeah awesome No
begone mr. Anderson I got to say the
blue pill goes down easier